you're watching local news with
nine-time Emmy Award winner Chet van
Jansen and now
here's chat
yep it's local news it's a segment where
each guest has to share a real news
story from wherever they're from and
then I vote on the winner and that
person gets to pick a lovely tea in our
tea bag showcase where is our tea bag
[Applause]
thank you
so uh is that what you're wearing
tonight yeah the maid outfits at the
cleaners oh
you left these at my place thank you
all right Jim
sorry is that the deputy of the steam
room yeah
I'll tell you one it's the fun and
defund
Jim yeah local news from where you are
you got something yep
um
you look anywhere I'm trying to remember
so yeah here you go
um I believe a man went outside do I
have to read this how's this guy no yeah
you can just tell us what happened Okay
so
so there's a noise outside of this guy's
door at night in Florida
and he goes out and uh there's an
alligator waiting for him so yeah this
is for I live in yeah that's right I
live in Florida you know first of all
number one you don't go outside at night
period there's rattlesnakes there's
Gators there's water moccasins there's
he said it there's not too many
Democrats where I live I'll tell you
that I'm in Naples they're like we gotta
get out of here
so what happened did it get eaten uh
supposedly what happened was I'm I'm
saying this is what he sounded like what
happened was I went outside and this is
what he said he said I felt I felt like
a bot and then it shook me violently but
I thought it was a dog or something or
perhaps a wild cat and then I I went
back in the house and I turned on I said
I'll be damned that's an alligator on
the front porch
so it's a gator on the front porch
waiting for this guy so great story
that's that's what you call local news
that's local news guy
where are you waiting where's your news
coming from I can't compete with that at
all
I'm just pointing out that the cherry
blossoms are back in Washington DC
and oh my God that is so that is so
local news yeah on points do do you have
a reporter there in front to show us
with all the tourists and all the
allergies and all of that and I would
like to personally invite you Greg to
come down and enjoy the time I lived I
lived in DC for a year uh that was the
only thing that DC had going for it
right right with the cherry blossoms
because the whole place just was
horrible well they've really cleaned up
the crime recently Greg so don't you
worry yes exactly
yeah I'm sure the homeless and the drag
addicts love the cherry blossoms right
it's all in full bloom yeah they just
grind it down and smoke it
is what I would do Dixon it says Dixon
Tudor
look I go by both do you go buy both
yeah all the time because people never
think Tudor's a real name yeah it's a
great name though you sound like a young
major league pitcher with a with a
substance abuse problem
23 year old Tudor Dixon had so much
potential
strip club his death is a local news
story his death has said yep they found
Tudor Dixon behind a dumpster of a Dixie
Mixie
had no pants on had an alligator bite
covered in cherry blossoms all right
tutor all right listen so I have a two
for because it's really good okay you
get
service dogs now in Michigan they are
taking these service dogs and having
them trained by prisoners so they're
going into the jails and the prisons
they're so they so the prisoners get the
service dog it makes them happy they've
murdered someone but they get to pass on
something good to the dog yes hopefully
and hopefully to the person that then
gets the dog because these people with
disabilities then they get the dog and
then the people with disabilities get
the dog and then the dog mugs them
because the dog learned the very word
the dog says let me show you how to make
toilet wine
who doesn't need toilets
the talks never sustained no but you
ever think about how hard they must have
laughed at like the first person to come
up with the idea of like Leader Dogs For
the Blind yeah the fact that that
actually was able to be seen through to
be an actual thing yeah and then kind of
inspiring and to find out it really
doesn't work it's all a scam I think it
works I know
are you okay yes tell me what is your
local story that was a great one so you
took the great one so this is that's why
it's all your fault that I had to pick
this which was that they found some
snails
at the airport they found big big snails
snails and they're both invasive and
delicious yeah but the first one is why
you can't travel with them especially
they also apparently can spread
meningitis which I'm anti they're live
right are they alive are they dead I
mean I I don't even know I think that
they're either alive or dead oh great
that's what's one of those two choices
could be any of those two
great job great reporting thank you back
to you Chet thanks Greg hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else